this was a very complex investigation
but one that was carried out
professionally and of course brought
about a unanimous verdict on five
charges five counts as they referred to
in the crown courts uh by the jury so in
that regard
um it's been a successful outcome but of
course the tragedy remains
um a nine-year-old little girl uh lost
her life because she was caught up
um innocently in basically what was a
drug swap
yeah Peter we're just looking at little
Olivia on the screen here today
um an important day for the family and
friends to to get Justice for her murder
and you talk about the case being
complex it was extremely difficult for
merseyside police for a number of
reasons that perhaps you can remind us
of one of them being Thomas cashman's
denial all along that he was involved as
far as we know he's shown no sign of
remorse or admission of guilt and it all
hinged
mainly on one witness one key Witness
well yes I mean you're referring to the
female witness that was uh um that
entered the witness protection scheme
now what I would say uh to our viewers
is the fact that
um that's a dramatic and major step
um in any in any criminal investigation
it needs to be dealt with legally uh
professionally and it's got to be
managed as well going forward so that
indicates and underlines I think the
significance of this witness to the
prosecution case but I would also
highlight that
um there was other elements of the
prosecution case that were that were um
put in front of the jury which for key
elements key parts of it particularly
the CCTV evidence that we saw now that
came from uh rigorous investigation by
Mark Baker's team in uncovering that and
also information which is analyzed and
turned into intelligence and eventually
played the part as evidence which was
volunteered by the public here on
merseyside so all in all this was a
really involved investigation it was
complex as a from the outset